day hey Hillary why' your H been visit
afan Island 26 times is this really
necessary is this really necessary guys
is this really necessary is this really
necessary sir so the man in the video is
Alex Rosen who's known for exposing
pedophiles this is part of what it's
become kind of a hobby it's one of the
few Trends I like on social media 26
times is think about that for a second
yeah like if you're friend said you want
to come to my Island and you'd be like I
guess once yeah but on the 25th time
what are you going there for well it's
Kevin spy Chris Tucker Bill Clinton on
that flight they're on their way
somewhere else cheap fuel I think he
plays it nonchalant the pilot is like oh
sorry say your captain speak I forgot to
fill up I don't know where we're gonna
oh I guess we have an island here
anybody want a massage by somebody with
small hands they try and T like oh what
about Republicans like if you understand
the history of Epstein and Donald Trump
we kicked them out of mar Lago as soon
as he found out that he was a creep